meine these ist dass gender sternchen
bin ich sagen männer wie sie aber es
nicht dargestellt sondern das sind
sinngemäß ja man möchte die menschen
klaglos und aus aber ich glaube ich
zivilistinnen und zivilisten die vor dem
gibt natürlich eine gewisse klientel in
glaube nicht dass friedrich merz anfang
beim scrabble spielen sie alle kennen
auch daran gewöhnen und hin führen dass
der in der bundespolitik die glaubt
wird sprechpausen so nach hoffe ich na
das spiel scrabble man legt wörter aus
krieg fliehen ins ausland das ist leider
man das sozusagen auch in seinen
dann geht er dann nicht mehr als sex ist
damit sich die mit einer solchen haltung
falsch in der sache weil die zivilisten
steinchen mit buchstaben und jetzt hat
normalen sprachbild nimmt und an manchen
ist ja nicht dürfen aber wie kann man
das war er doch mal vorwürfe in der
der hersteller von scrabble nämlich
universitäten kriegt man ja quasi was
ich gehe da nicht die zustimmung des
überhaupt einen solchen begriff zivilist
hinsicht vielleicht ist das ja ganz gut
mattel gesagt also wir machen das kleine
abgezogen wenn man nicht geändert wenn
innen erfinden die aktivistinnen und
stammtisches zu holen aber stammt dass
um sich neu zu erfinden für märz also
gender sternchen da dazu sternchen ii
sie hält sternchen arbeit was oder licht
zivilisten habe ich überhaupt keine
erstens ist friedrich merz kein sex ist
entsteht ist überall dabei man bekommt
es eine gewisse teile der bevölkerung
schreiben sie also also also wahnsinn
probleme ich scheue mich was noch
und zweitens ist eine anbiederung auch
sind der normalen kitchen table politics
man solle nicht nur zu ändern man
akustisch einfach immer ein bisschen so
bekommt auch noch fett extra-punkte wenn
dass man sozusagen für eine laut duden
immer das schlechteste was man machen
also im grunde diejenigen die über
man geändert nämlich zehn mehr das
kann man muss in der politik authentisch
berührt dass sind diese zivilistinnen
korrekte schreibweise etwas abgezogen
werden und immer wichtiger sind
kriegt man sonst nur wenn wir eine
sein und von daher also ich kann mit den
natürlich von den normalen themen und
bekommt hier kriegt man in einem spiel
besonderheit schafft nämlich dass den
wenn jemand dann innehält und diese
jenseits berlin-mitte nichts mit dem
was sich ja eigentlich der
kunst pause macht um beide geschlechter
buchstaben y oder kuh zu verwenden ich
sprach pausen beim cenelec nichts
gebaren ihr zu tun haben nur das wird
rechtschreibung verschrieben hat für
einzubringen das hat sich mir noch nicht
eine grundfalsche schreibweise extra
anfangen ja das ist auch nicht besonders
finde aber frauen und non binäre
sich radikal ändern weil auch am kitchen
so ganz vermitteln aber ich meine wir
ästhetisch
punkte während ich als
menschen sind keine besonderheit die
table am küchentisch sitzen junge frauen
bundestagsabgeordneter sie sind doch
haben sonst pause ist dafür da dass die
brauchen keine bevormundung und sie
sicher auch schon mal leidenschaftlich
müssen nicht herausgestellt werden das
in diese einfordert werden und danach
geschwärmt denn ja nicht männer und
schafft er das gegenteil das hilft ihm
geworden am rednerpult von bildern aus
frauen sind dafür ist die kunst
überhaupt nicht die sind mündig die
gegen leider leider bin ich auch fragen
ausgeteilt ausgerastet gegen die anderen
können auf sich selbst aufpassen und ich
und ich bin ja wie gar nicht zum ersten
ist es klingt das ein bisschen
parteien und ich habe eine rede sehen
glaube dass ihnen die firma mattel hier
ambitioniert oder durch angriffe
eher einen bärendienst erweist und ich
von müller fest kennen sie das ist eine
mal hier verunglimpft er it's an kein
stammtisch ich habe nie daran gesetzt
glaube dass dieser wahnsinn ein ende
grünzone ich habe es die jüngste
sie haben doch in
haben muss china wo waren sind ein ende
abgeordnete ja und dass thaksin die
werden die da sitzen ist das ja nein das
cambridge studiert man das ist doch
haben wirklich stimmt wieder
ist kein
100-prozentig zu und das schlimmste ist
freundinnen
england ist auch das große land der
jedenfalls vehement dagegen und ich
für mich immer ich wurde letztens auch
liberalität an diesen universitäten ist
wieder eingeladen als gäste das habe ich
und ich dachte so hormann die arme da
glaube auch nicht dass das so kommen
man doch ein absoluter freigeist
dann direkt abgelehnt diese einladungen
ist sie so in rage und das ganze riecht
wird die ich habe noch nie im privaten
per email weil ich keine gäste in bin
warum dann so verengt und so spießig
irgendwie so ein schluck wasser in der
zusammenhang gehört dass eine junge frau
kurve auseinander weil sie ihnen sagen
ich bin ein gast und früher in der
geändert hätte beim reden noch nicht
sekunden mensch ist doch toll sprache
am schluss soll ist die emi die kollegin
schule wenn der lehrer gerufen hat alle
einmal weil das doch mit fester das
verändert sich wenn menschen das
fester soll soll reden wie sie will
schüler gehen jetzt raus vorjahr da
trinken bitte emilia fester die grünen
annehmen und tun wir schreiben ja auch
sollte es in ihrem privatbereich machen
stand ich nicht daran hab gesagt moment
nicht mehr in sütterlin dann kann man
aus und kann ja sein dass die bundeswehr
im zweifel auch weil es ihr so in
ich bin eine schülerin ich bin nicht
in einem privaten zusammenhang noch
angesprochen ich bleibe hier sitzen wir
auch sagen ich spiele muss eine solche
fleisch und blut übergegangen ist am
der feuerprobe ich finde ländern ist
keine junge frau gesehen oder auch eine
rednerpult des deutschen bundestags aber
neue kommunikation
ältere überhaupt eine frau die gern auch
mir soll keiner vorschreiben dass ich so
anti feministische weil man immer
reden ja ich sage trotzdem voraussetzt
dem feld reicht sie haben wir vorhin
komplett auf das geschlecht zeigen muss
keinen annehmen übrigen da spielt im
aber mit mattel also als mattel einen
einiger vor der nächsten bundestagswahl
normalen leben gar keine rolle und es
selber her jeder überleben können doch
wird weiterhin keine rolle spielen
werden sie im bundestag zu ändern das
sondern es spielt eine rolle für
mehr jungen mann rausgebracht hat da war
jeder so leben können wie er will nein
bestimmte viertel in der politik die
glaub ich glaube sie wird also tut das
es für mich sowieso schon vorbei mit dem
so hoch wie das von ihnen gewalt vor
einfach sagen ich habe mal nicht so gut
glauben damit ihrer modernität beweisen
boban so in der firma für kinder ja es
gefahren aber die haben sich auch im
dass die firma mattel auch noch mittel
zu müssen und es spielt eine rolle in
sind pr machen und den leuten ist damit
letzten wahlkampf nicht komplett dagegen
in das ein spezielles wort anbietet mit
nicht geholfen und es ist wahr dass es
gestellt als union gegen das zu ändern
feministischen kreisen die glauben damit
eine chancenungleichheit gibt in
oder weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
gender sternchen nämlich putin
druck ausüben zu können auf die
gesellschaft diesem druck muss man
für mich war das jetzt ein thema was ein
deutschland aber solche pr gags helfen
wenn du nicht selber sternchen da gibt
wieder stehen
gewinn weil es mich ehrlich gesagt in
nicht im gegenteil sie stellen alle
meinem wahlkreis von den bürgerinnen und
dürfen wir gespannt also ich habe nichts
es 20 extra punkte weil das hat man noch
bürgern nicht ich will darauf nicht
leute die jetzt hier zu ändern wollen im
nie gesehen ehrlich dieses land ist so
dagegen wenn man wenn es sinn macht
scrabble und die sich da dann
angesprochen am schluss ist es für mich
angesprochen fühlen als merkwürdig
verrückt hier gibt es
schülerinnen und schüler sagt dann sind
ein kondom nicht thema weil es uns davon
heraus als müssten sie extra bepunktet
sexismus in der linken große debatte und
nämlich ja da sind offen das ist von
werden weil sie sonst nicht schaffen
ablenkt uns mit den themen zu
jabra stone aber sozusagen gemeint das
weil dass sie etwas besonderes selten
beschäftigen die wirklich wichtig sind
das sind wie der buchstabe q der ypsilon
gender sternchen bei scrabble das steht
ist kunst sprache kunst sprache als
sicherheit wirtschaft dass die leute was
ich glaube das ist einfach ein eigentor
nebeneinander wie sind wir eigentlich
stern.de radeln außer dann zwischendurch
zu essen in wirklichkeit bestimmt es
es entstehen in dieser zeit ja auch neue
drauf
die mehrmals im deutschlandfunk immer
nicht sind natürlich ein thema und ich
wörter die man noch nie gehört hat mich
und so
übergebraten wird klar habe ich
hat's gerissen als sich erste mal im
erwog wahnsinn aber das sind doch das
tatsächlich das noch dass das
radio nachrichten gehört habe
habe doch genau die wohlstands
zivilistinnen und zivilisten
diskussionen der letzten fünf bis zehn
zur nächsten bundestagswahl nicht der
das muss man natürlich sorgfältig
jahre die jetzt dazu geführt dass wir
fall sein sie sind möglich denn wenn
auseinander halten weil zivilistinnen in
dem kunden überhaupt nicht mehr genieren
aldi erweiterung sind aber noch mal
herr merz mal auf einer in einer
der ukraine gehen ja eher ins ausland um
zurückzukommen auf auf das thema was
wahlkampfrede geändert dann wissen wir
sich in sicherheit zu bringen mit den
mich am meisten ärgert ist sozusagen
kindern die zivilisten wiederum werden
dieses bevormundende was da drin ich hab
dass sein vater nicht verloren dann
zwar mehr einberufen so wird das aber
mir das heute auf der homepage schon
könnte mit den grünen fusion alles
angeschaut da steht irgendwie so
[Gelächter]